from the filmmaker who ruined not one
not two but three different superheroes
comes Catwoman for men daredevil
before Netflix and Marvel Studios team
up to hopefully do the character justice
return to the early 2000s when superhero
movies were still full of crappy CGI
matrix age Sopranos and Izzy's listen
Fisk is in the hizzy
fresh off Pearl Harbor Angie Lee 2003 's
least favorite actor Ben Affleck stars
as Matt Murdock a boy granted
superpowers after running face-first
into an absurd amount of gigantic
unsecured toxic waste containers with
his eyesight taken from him he'll use
his other four senses to see perfectly
yet still dress up like a blond guy to
score sympathy points with hot chicks
wait blinds
yeah I am so sorry
which gives Ben Affleck an excuse to
show off his stupid cross-eyed derp face
ermahgerd it's the Derb devil by day is
a lawyer whose terrible at his job
another rapist back on the streets but
by night he's the daredevil a vigilante
who beats up the man he's too
incompetent to prosecute I was quittin
and let's innocent people die so we can
have pg-13 sex with Jennifer Garner I
have to go stay with me cheer for a
superhero who's barely more powerful
than your average Cobb as this poor poor
man spider-man fights crime with an odd
grab bag of powers like super jump a
creepy smelling and super heart rate
monitoring so he's a human lie detector
and he still can win a case
Wow just wow along for the ride on
Daredevils generic directionless quest
for justice his elektra natchios a girl
who for the first half of the movie is
really just there to look hard you are
so good
I'm sure look beautiful beautiful thing
and while until it beautiful fear so
hard that Matt will add stalking and
sexual harassment to his growing list of
crimes wait a minute wait a second take
it easy
not all like being touched watch the
time what you do like we'll start there
see kids if a girl doesn't like you beat
her up until she changes her mind
witness the least subtle superhero movie
since Batman and Robin as Elektra and
daredevil team of against a kingpin a
man who wants to be a kingpin and
bullseye a man who targets things as if
the giant can target on his head was it
enough of a giveaway bullseye but if you
still manage to get lost don't worry
because Ben Affleck will explain
everything in voiceover that sounds like
he's just waking up from a coma my sense
of sound gave off a kind of radar sense
there are days when I believe and others
who I've lost all faith I had set out to
save the city but with Electress help I
saved myself instead sorry what so
settle in for what's basically Ben
Affleck's really disappointing audition
to be the next Batman where he plays a
brooding loner who becomes a vigilante
crime fighter after his dad is murdered
by criminals in an alley uses a
ridiculous Batman voice when he's in
costume what do you want justice stay
out of Hell's Kitchen travels by
grappling hook
he's scared of bats and refuses to kill
oh wait never mind he'll totally kill
I'm not the bad guy yeah you kind of are
though starring a soundtrack full of the
2000s worst new metal bands p OD
Hoobastank cedar drowning pool
Evanescence Evanescence again and
Nickelback batfleck begins
um shouldn't that be in Braille be sure
to subscribe for more honest trailers
don't ever call me kitty if karma
doesn't come around and slap you in the
face I will I'm a banana I'm a banana
I'm a banana look at me move I'm here
for the money the tacos are blue I was
frozen today